[Music]
Iceland was first settled from Norway in
the days of King Harald fine hair the
son of health down the black according
to the reckoning of the wisest man I
know my foster father Tate son of Bishop
ice leaf and of my uncle thorkil
garrison who remember the long way back
and of thurid daughter of Snorri the
priest who was both wise and were
informed the settlement of Iceland took
place at the time when iva the son of
Ragnar hairy breeches had st. Edmund
king of the English killed and according
to st. Edmund's saga that happened eight
hundred and seventy years after the
birth of Christ
the story goes and it is a true one that
a Norwegian called
engulfed traveled from Norway to Iceland
for the first time when Harald fine hair
was 16 years old and again a few years
later he settled to the south in
Reykjavik the place where he landed
first is called engulfs head to the east
of minth acts Scholl and the place where
he later settled his Engels fell which
lies to the east of the old Fox River in
those days there were trees growing in
Iceland between the mountains and the
shore there were also Christian men here
whom the Norseman called papa but they
left afterward because they did not want
to live alongside heathens
[Music]
they left behind some Irish bulk spells
and Croesus from which it may be deduced
that they were Irish men after that a
great number of people began to migrate
here from Norway until king harald
banned the practice fearing that his
land would be depopulated otherwise then
it was agreed that anyone coming here
from norway would have to pay the king
five pieces of gold unless he was
granted an exemption King Harald is said
to have been king for seventy years and
to have reached the age of 80 this is
the origin of the tax called land our
land money the tax was sometimes higher
and sometimes lower until Olaf the stout
made it definite that anyone traveling
between Norway and Iceland had to pay
the king half a mark
except for women and the men he exempted
Raquel garrison was our source for this
after Iceland had been extensively
settled a Norwegian called alpha jot
brought the first laws here from Norway
Tate was the one who gave an account of
this the laws were called alpha watts
laws these laws were largely based on
the good thing law or on the judgment of
Thor Leif the wise son of Hoth akari
when a law needed to be extended or
abolished or modified in some way both
food rots foster-brother was said to be
grimm goats hair on all food rots advice
this Grimm surveyed the whole of Iceland
before the ALF thing was established as
payment for this every man in the
country contributed a penny to him and
afterwards he gave that money to temples
you
[Music]